it's actually a funny story about the
gang Maris bell comes up to me was like
Hey man take this C4 this will how you
go for like three sacks and I was like
I'm good bro like I don't need that
stuff so then he like man just take it
straight to the head I was like man I
see everybody doing it and I do want to
go off today so and this is why I say
don't fall for peer pressure so I took
it and I tried to swallow it no water
and I was like oh oh man like sheesh I
hit the field the first three plays my
heart was
like I'm like yo oh I'm pushing through
it cuz I'm like maybe I got to get my
second win right so I'm getting to the
sideline I'm like coach I can't breathe
dog like my Hearts on Fire he's like are
you good to go I said no like give me
some help bro my man he's like just
breathe bro go get the oxygen I was like
bro I just got throw up like that's the
only way so I went to the side and I
just pulled that trigger and that's why
I was like I'm cool off the see for life
just be careful when you trying new
stuff cuz like I was scared for my life
for a little bit